good afternoon and welcome to sky news
at one breaking news and the uk is
experiencing its hottest ever day after
the met office issued a red extreme heat
warning in an area stretching between
london manchester and york the public
have been warned not to travel in the
so-called red zone and this lunchtime
coast guard teams have rescued five
people and are searching for a missing
man after an incident at clacton pier
and the met office has a provisional
temperature of 40.2
degrees celsius was reached at heathrow
and temperatures are continuing to rise
this guy's meteorologist joanna robinson
she was in west london we're going to
chat to her in a bit because that new
record has been set at heathrow it was
reported at 12
50 p.m on tuesday that's according to
provisional met office figures so the
temperature over 40 degrees celsius you
remember going into this heat wave we
were told 80 chance we would break 40
degrees and we have now so it's exceeded
40 degrees in the uk for the first time
ever 40.2 degrees reported at heathrow
airport 12 50 pm on tuesday today that's
according to provisional met office
figures now